on friday november 22nd 1963 president
john f kennedy was assassinated in
dallas texas
his killer lee harvey oswald fired three
shots from the texas school book
depository and one of those shots killed
the president oswald acted alone not as
part of any conspiracy in 45 words i
just gave you the basic story of the
kennedy assassination a watershed moment
in history
however possibly 80 percent or of the
people watching this video or maybe even
more will likely think that some or most
of the 45 words i just said are somehow
wrong
and three words in particular which also
appear in the title of this video oswald
acted alone i'm sean munger i'm a
historian and i'm about to take you on a
journey into the heart of a much
misunderstood event in american history
this is a very long video which i've
broken into two segments which are meant
to go together and in which i'll lay out
the basic historical facts of the
kennedy assassination of 1963
and i hope to prove to you my thesis
which is right there in the title that
oswald kennedy's killer acted alone in
doing so
[Music]
before we get started i want to say a
couple of words about myself about the
structure of this two video series and
to give you a road map as to where we're
going
i have a doctorate in history and i
teach history both online and in person
i've had historical writing
peer-reviewed published in professional
outlets in both the u.s and europe
if you're a regular viewer of my channel
maybe you've seen some of my other stuff
i am drawn to historical mysteries and
also to nautical subjects ships and
ocean liners particularly although
obviously this video is not about that
i've done some previous videos about
false historical narratives of history
or other misconceptions of history
for example back in 2017 i did a series
on the 200 year old legends of buried
treasure on oak island
nova scotia in canada
i've talked about the ancient aliens
hypothesis and how history can be faked
this one on the kennedy assassination is
only the second of the truly long form
historical videos that i've done the
previous one from june 2022 is about the
meaning of the titanic disaster
now i realize this video is extremely
long and covers a lot of ground
as you might imagine there's a lot to
talk about with the kennedy
assassination i do not expect a lot of
people will watch the segments all the
way through from beginning to end though
of course you are welcome to do that if
you wish
instead the way i suggest you navigate
these videos is through the chapters
i've tried to delineate them as clearly
as possible by subject and they're
numbered 1-36 this one's one of course
36 is the conclusion and i'm going to
put up on the screen here a scrolling
list of all the chapters which are
identified as i said by subject
thus you can skip around if you like
does the grassy null interest you that's
chapter 10
want to know about the murder of dallas
police officer
jd tippett that's chapter 12 the
garrison investigation oliver stone's
movie jfk chapter 26
if a subject that you want isn't in the
first half it's probably in the second
half
[Music]
i do suggest you start though with the
first couple of chapters in this video
this part one which are conceptual and
will lay the groundwork for stuff i'll
be talking about later
as you'll see there's a certain
methodology to my thinking and you
deserve to understand what that is
something else i'll be doing which i
don't usually do in my videos but i
should probably start doing it more
often is i'm going to show citations to
my sources
now i can't put links to all of them in
the description or on cards within the
video itself so what i'm going to do is
i'm going to show them on the screen
when they relate to an important fact
for example if it was especially
important that you know i'm just pulling
a fact at random that kennedy's plane
touched down at love field in dallas at
11 40 a.m on november 22nd i'll give you
the site on the screen like this
and then if you wanted to you could
actually get the source look it up and
see yes it really does say on page 19
that the plane landed at 11 40 am so you
see how this works oh you might have
just noticed that i just cited the
warren report there now if you're a
critic of the warren commission and its
conclusions
which are that oswald did it and that he
did it alone you might think oh no
that's not a reliable source well first
of all it is see chapter 21 for a
discussion of that issue
and you might also want to ask yourself
if the war on report is so unreliable
how come it is the number one source
cited by conspiracy authors for various
facts in their own books
[Music]
one of the other sources that i'll be
citing is this book which is gigantic
and heavy
this is called reclaiming history by
vincent bouliosi published in 2007
and it is far and away the best and most
comprehensive book ever written on the
kennedy assassination
so if you want to learn about this event
i strongly suggest you start with this
book yes it is over 1700 pages and yes i
have read them all
including the footnotes another 958
pages and the source notes 170 more
pages
those came incidentally on a separate
cd-rom
with the original edition of the book
you can say i've already lost mine but i
i preserve them on computer files
vincent bulliosi the author of this book
was a lawyer first a prosecutor and
later a private criminal defense lawyer
and he was also an author and historian
he was very famous made famous for
prosecuting the manson family in 1970
in 1986 bouiosi took part in a mock
trial of lee harvey oswald which was
televised for a british tv network
and this trial utilized actual evidence
called real-life witnesses not actors
and even empaneled a jury drawn from the
voter rolls of dallas texas from 1963.
booliosi was the prosecutor and his case
was that oswald was the murderer of
kennedy and acted alone the jury in that
case came back with a verdict of guilty
the exhaustive sources and notes that
buliosi collected for that mock trial
formed the basis of that book which took
him 22 years to complete mr boliosi
passed away in 2015.
so anyway that's the road map before we
begin i want to spend a very brief time
outlining the basic facts of the
assassination this is the general
framework of what happened
the assassination occurred in dealey
plaza in downtown dallas texas which
still exists mostly in its original form
today
one of the buildings fronting this plaza
is the building that was in 1963 the
texas school book depository
where lee harvey oswald aged 24 worked
stacking boxes and filling orders
oswald identified himself as a communist
and had attempted several months before
to assassinate a u.s army general
president kennedy the 35th president was
elected in 1960 and had come to dallas
on a trip to shore up the splintering
texas democratic party in advance of his
anticipated 1964 re-election campaign
kennedy rode in this limousine in the
motorcade and in that car he was
accompanied by his wife jackie
and texas governor john connolly vice
president lyndon johnson was in another
car behind them
at 12 30 p.m on this day
november 22nd 1963 three shots rang out
in dealey plaza president kennedy was
hit by two of those three shots one of
those two went on to wound governor john
connolly and the other probably the
third shot fired struck the president in
the head he never regained consciousness
despite being rushed to parkland
hospital and he died not long after
lyndon johnson was sworn in as the 36th
president aboard air force one just
before it took off bringing kennedy's
body back to washington
lee harvey oswald immediately fled the
texas school book depository just before
police sealed it off when they searched
the building which is where the shots
came from they found oswald's monlicker
carcano rifle laying on the floor in a
nest of book boxes around the sixth
floor window they also found the shell
casings of the three bullets that he
fired his fingerprints were found all
over the rifle and the boxes
oswald caught a city bus and he went
back to his rooming house across town
where he was staying he grabbed a 38
revolver changed clothes and then went
back out
shortly after that when approached by a
policeman in a car j.d tippett oswald
shot the policeman dead and ran away by
now his description was all over the
wires and he was shortly apprehended in
the texas theater a movie theater oswald
was taken to dallas police headquarters
interrogated he made a few statements to
the press and was charged that night
with the murders of president kennedy
and officer tibbett
a decision was made to move him to the
county jail just as that move was
getting started this was on sunday
morning november 24th jack ruby a dallas
nightclub owner who was enraged by the
assassination ran into the parking
garage at the police building and shot
oswald who died shortly after the new
president lyndon johnson established a
special federal commission to
investigate the assassination it was
headed by supreme court chief justice
earl warren hence its name the warren
commission the commission issued its
reports along with 26 volumes of
supporting material in september 1964.
it concluded that oswald did it and that
he had acted alone there was a second
investigation of the assassination in
the late 1970s called the house select
committee on assassinations which was
independent of the warren commission
the hsca in its final report concluded
that there was likely a conspiracy
however as i explained in chapter 29
that conclusion was reached erroneously
as a result of a single bit of evidence
that was in short order proven beyond
all doubt to have been erroneously
construed by the hsca
if not for that piece of evidence which
was a tape recording by the way the hsca
would have concluded exactly what the
warren commission had done earlier that
oswald committed the assassination and
that he acted alone
so those are the basic facts now let's
move on to some conceptual issues and
then in short order into the evidence
itself
[Music]
okay maybe the title of this chapter
exaggerates a little bit
the opinion it's not an opinion but a
conclusion that lee harvey oswald
assassinated john f kennedy and that he
acted alone and not as part of a
conspiracy is a minority view in america
according to polling americans belief in
a conspiracy in the jfk assassination
has never been lower than 52 percent
and was clocked at a whopping 81 percent
of the public in april 2001. because of
that fact alone i'm kind of an outlier
and i'm quite certain that many viewers
here on youtube will be extremely
offended by the mere premise of this
video and we'll take to the comments to
denounce me which is why all comments
will be strictly moderated by the way
who am i to say that 8 out of 10
americans are wrong about this issue
assuming that that 81 percent number is
still valid today
well they are wrong and there's just no
two ways about that now i'm not trying
to be arrogant about this at all
but i've given a very careful reading of
the historical facts
and the conclusion that lee harvey
oswald killed john f kennedy and that he
did it alone is not only probable but
certain yes certain meaning there's no
doubt and i honestly don't believe that
there is any doubt
it's not close it's not a horse race and
you can't just back away from the issue
by saying well we can't really know what
happened on that day actually we can in
fact we do know what happened that day
and we also know what did not happen
so in this video i'll set out to show
how and why we know what we know and
some of those facts may surprise you
there are reasons why so many americans
don't believe the historical fact that
oswald acted alone i'll get into some of
those broader reasons in chapter 34
about why many people want to believe
that there that it was a conspiracy but
closer to ground level i think that the
number one reason why so many people
believe that it was a conspiracy is
because they don't know a lot of the
true facts about the real event and what
they think they know often tends to be
wrong
so here are my nominations for the most
important facts about the kennedy
assassination that people don't know
these are just three facts out of
hundreds but these three standing alone
i think are pretty persuasive
fact number one
the bullet that killed john f kennedy
and fragments of bullets from oswald's
other two shots were proven by
ballistics experts ballistics analysis
to have been fired from oswald's rifle
to the exclusion of all other rifles in
the world
it was his gun proven his bullets proven
most people don't know how conclusively
this fact has been established
fact number two a couple of months
before in april 1963
oswald used that exact same rifle to try
to kill someone else retired army
general edwin walker oswald himself
admitted that he did this he told his
wife
we'll talk about the walker attempt in
chapter 12.
now some people are amazed when i tell
them that oswald had tried to do this
kind of thing before and in fact that he
used the same gun
the usual reaction is
gee i didn't know that how come i didn't
know that well the reason you didn't
know that is because conspiracy
theorists authors and filmmakers who
produced lots of stuff about the jfk
assassination
generally don't include any mention of
the walker attempt because it makes
oswald look really guilty which in fact
he is
fact number three
there were hundreds of eyewitnesses to
the assassination who all saw pretty
much the same thing but there was one
particular eyewitness who actually saw
oswald shooting kennedy from the sixth
floor window in the school book
depository
that man's name was howard brennan and
he was sitting on a concrete wall in
dealey plaza and he happened to be
looking directly at the school book
depository at the moment the shots were
fired i looked directly across
and up
possibility of a 45 degree angle
and this man
same man i had saw
prior to the president's arrival
was
in the window and taking
aim for his last shot
after
he fired the
last or the third shot or
he
didn't seem to be in a great rush
hurry
he
seemed to pause for a moment to see if
for sure he accomplished his purpose
and he brought the gun back
to rest in upright position
as though
he was satisfied
not only did he see the gun poking out
of the sixth floor window he clearly saw
the man who fired it he gave a
description of that man to the police it
was accurate and then later that day
november 22 he identified oswald
personally in a police lineup as the man
who had done it
other witnesses though they did not see
the gun actually fire also did see
oswald at the window
now most people don't realize that there
was an eyewitness to oswald actually
shooting president kennedy someone saw
him do it and identified him and the
identification was corroborated by other
witnesses now that's pretty conclusive
now on the flip side here are three fake
facts that people think they know about
the assassination and they don't usually
realize are fake
fake fact number one the bullet that
killed president kennedy or that wounded
president kennedy had did some sort of
physics-defying maneuver in mid-air
usually referred to as an s-turn this is
false
in chapter eight i'll explain why the
so-called magic bullet didn't do
anything magical at all and i'll explain
how this misconception got started and
how deceptive conspiracy theorists
continued to perpetuate it the bullet
was not pristine either by the way which
is another claim false claim made by
conspiracy theorists
fake fact number two
oswald could not have fired three shots
from the rifle in the time proven by the
subrouter film that the shots had to
have been fired in now that is false
not only could he do that but he did do
that and the feat was easily replicated
by investigators after the assassination
in fact the fbi sharpshooter who tried
it with the exact same gun
even improved on oswald's time i'll
discuss that in chapter seven
fake fact number three
jack ruby the dallas nightclub owner who
shot lee harvey oswald on november 24th
1963 silenced oswald for the mafia that
is false ruby did not work for the mafia
he wasn't sent by anybody he just did it
on his own and i can prove it and i'll
discuss it in chapter 16 and i'll give
my citations there
so there you have it three things that
most people don't know about the jfk
assassination and three things that many
people think they know but which are
false
the historical facts about the
assassination have been crowded out by
innuendo distortions and flat out
fabrications to the point where real
facts almost never get a hearing
this is why bouiosi
entitled his book reclaiming history he
felt that historians had to reclaim the
kennedy assassination from the
conspiracy theorists who have muddled it
unfortunately it's a sad reality that
for many people facts don't matter when
i was getting my phd in history my ta ta
stands for a teaching assistant i ta'ed
for a class in 20th century american
history this is at the university level
i gave a quiz to my class which included
a multiple choice question about the
kennedy assassination it was very simple
who killed john f kennedy a the mafia b
the military c lee harvey oswald or d
the soviets obviously the correct answer
was c
one student who did mark the correct
answer c added a note in the margin and
the note read quote i know this is the
answer you want but this is not what i
believe end quote
note that choice of words this is not
what i believe as if it's a religion
so if you're in this category if you're
unwilling to consider the facts in the
kennedy assassination i recommend you
stop watching this video right now i'll
only waste your time go watch some i
don't know cat videos or something like
that
the analysis that i'm going to go
through depends on facts and on logical
conclusions drawn from those facts
now facts don't matter to you and if you
cling to a conclusion about what
happened on november 22nd 1963 simply
out of faith then there's nothing really
i could do for you and you probably
won't enjoy this video anyway so go
watch some cat videos
[Music]
before we begin with the facts of the
kennedy assassination it's worth putting
the whole event into historical context
and to do that we need to take a look at
a few other events in american history
kennedy was one of four u.s presidents
who were murdered for the record the
others were abraham lincoln shot by john
wilkes booth in 1865 james garfield shot
by charles g guiteau in 1881 and william
mckinley shot by leon salgaz in 1901
in addition to these four successful
attempts let's look at five others that
are relevant
in 1835 a man named richard lawrence
attempted to assassinate president
andrew jackson walked up to him with two
loaded pistols both pistols misfired
in 1912 former president theodore
roosevelt was shot at a campaign rally
by a man named joseph flamong shrunk
roosevelt survived
in 1933 president-elect franklin d
roosevelt was shot at by a man named
giuseppe zangara
fdr seems to have been the target but
zangara did successfully kill the mayor
of chicago who was standing next to fdr
in 1975 squeaky fromm a member of the
charles manson cult attempted to
assassinate president gerald ford her
gun misfired
and finally in 1981 john hinckley shot
president ronald reagan at the
washington hilton hotel i did a video
about that
reagan was hit but survived there have
been various other attempts to kill us
presidents throughout history but these
five unsuccessful attempts are generally
considered the most serious
so let's take all of these
assassinations and attempts together all
nine and what you see is a clear pattern
with one exception all of these cases
involve lone wolf assassins not working
with others as part of some deep dyed
plot
in some cases the assailants were
mentally ill or on the verge of mental
illness and in others and sometimes both
there was to some degree a political
motive to most of them
charles guiteau president garfield's
assassin was absolutely and clearly
deranged he had a lifelong struggle with
mental illness and there was no
suggestion or evidence that he worked
with anyone else
leon sulgaz who killed president
mckinley in 1901 was not suffering from
mental illness most likely but his
motive was purely political he was an
anarchist and a rather extreme anarchist
who saw himself as striking a blow
against oppression and oligarchy
similarly zangara who attempted to
assassinate fdr had a political motive
richard lawrence history of mental
illness squeaky from political motive
part of the whole charles manson
helter-skelter thing john hinckley no
political motive clearly a mental
illness
now the one outlier is the lincoln
assassination that was a conspiracy
booth and several associates including
lewis payne david harold and george
atzeroth hatched a plan to decapitate
the u.s government at the end of the
civil war by assassinating top leaders
lincoln vice president andrew johnson
secretary of state william seward and
possibly at one point they were going to
kill union general ulysses s grant
each of the men in the conspiracy was
assigned a target but booth was the only
one who was successful in killing his
intended target
now this was undoubtedly a conspiracy
but it was a fairly small one only a
handful of people they were not
government officials or part of some
powerful organization they were
confederate sympathizers private
citizens with political motives
in the lincoln case the conspiracy was
uncovered immediately it was obvious to
everyone that there was a conspiracy
because lewis payne stabbed william
seward at the same roughly the same time
that booth was shooting lincoln
so here's the point i'm making again
setting lincoln aside all the other
times in u.s history that a presidential
assassin has been successful or almost
successful they were acting alone no
conspiracy and the one time that was not
true the lincoln case the conspiracy was
small and it was instantly apparent
so logically why shouldn't we consider
that the kennedy assassination would be
more like those other prior events in
american history rather than unlike them
now this is not conclusive by any means
but logically shouldn't the default
position be given how those other events
unfolded that this one is likely to
follow the same pattern political motive
or mental illness but no conspiracy
so what i'm getting at is that in u.s
history there's a precedent not
president but precedent
for an assassination by a lone wolf with
a political motive whereas there is no
precedent anywhere in american history
for the kind of massive institutional
conspiracy to kill a president that most
conspiracy theorists allege in the jfk
case
the cia the military the mafia never
conspired to assassinate a u.s president
before and they have not since so why
should this case be different i've gone
through this analysis at the outset
before we get to the physical and
logical evidence in the jfk case to set
the stage
even before examining that evidence we
already have a default setting a pattern
which this case is likely to fit because
it happened something like this before
and that pattern is no conspiracy at all
or if there is one we would have noted
unequivocally at the time okay sorry to
delay but let's do one more logical
setup before we get into the evidence
that's the next chapter
[Music]
this chapter does not involve the facts
of the jfk assassination but it's
important to establish a mode of
reasoning that will become extremely
relevant as we get into the facts
it's epistemology if you will basically
how do we know that something happened
and how do we judge the relevance of
individual facts
in the context of a broader story so
let's take this exercise
suppose that a bank is robbed at midday
in the downtown of a major city the
robber does not wear a mask
he walks up to the counter points a gun
at the teller and demands all all the
cash in a bag the teller gives him a
canvas bag full of ten thousand dollars
in cash but slips a die bomb inside the
bag the robber walks out and his face is
clearly caught on a security camera
thirty minutes after the robbery a man
named jake is arrested across town in
his car he has a bunch of cash totaling
nine thousand dollars which is the bills
are stained with purple dye his hands
are stained with purple dye he's wearing
different clothes than what the robber
was wearing but he matches the
description perfectly ten witnesses
identified jake in various lineups as
the bank robber
a gun is found in jake's car matching
the one used in the robbery it's
registered to him and it has his
fingerprints on it
so as straightforward as this story is
suppose there are a couple of odd
discrepancies let's call these the odd
facts
first neither the canvas bag presumably
stained with the purple dye nor the
other one thousand dollars is ever found
second a friend of jake's insists that
he saw jake at a bar across town at the
exact moment that the robbery was taking
place
third the place where jake was
apprehended is unusually far from the
bank in terms of the amount of distance
that he could have covered in noontime
traffic
and fourth we don't know how he changed
clothes
so suppose all of this evidence is
presented at a trial prosecution
presents the money the die the
fingerprints the gun the security camera
footage the 10 eyewitnesses and jake's
girlfriend who testifies that he told
her the night before that he was
planning to rob a bank and the defense
puts on the odd facts
so what logical inference do we draw
from the totality of the evidence
well clearly the prosecution's facts
demonstrate that jake robbed the bank
the evidence is absolutely overwhelming
the money the die the fingerprints the
gun the eyewitnesses the security camera
jake's girlfriend jake robbed the bank
we can be extremely confident of that
conclusion
now here's the key point
once we decide and were justified in
deciding that jake robbed the bank the
odd facts however they got to be that
way
have to line up with the conclusion that
we know to be true
what happened to the canvas bag or the
other one thousand dollars that was
never found
we don't know but whatever happened to
it by definition cannot alter the
conclusion that jake robbed the bank
in fact what happened to the canvas bag
by definition can't be a very important
fact it might be interesting to know but
it can't be that important because it
can't affect the outcome
so what about that eyewitness who said
that he saw jake at the bar
well the existence of this story must be
consistent with what we already know to
be true the witness may be lying that
would be consistent with what we know to
be true he might also be telling the
truth he might have seen a person who
looked like jake or jake might really
have been there but the witness got the
time wrong or he might honestly have
wanted jake to be not guilty so bad that
he talked himself into believing that he
was there
whatever the explanation for this odd
fact even if it's an unusual or exotic
explanation for why the witness
testified as he did it has to be
consistent with what we already know to
be true
now it would be a different story if
there was stronger evidence that jake
really was at the bar and that his
friend really did see him if 10 people
saw him there for example if there was a
credit card receipt proving that he
bought a drink at the exact moment the
bank was being robbed that would be
different
but if that was the case how could the
rest of the evidence that he was robbing
the bank at that moment be so strong
now take that other odd fact that jake
seems to have gotten unusually far away
from the bank in the 30 minutes before
the police caught up to him
now it might be out of line with what we
would expect in the abstract
but if we can conclude from the rest of
the evidence that jake did rob the bank
then by definition however unlikely it
might have seemed he must have gotten
that distance away from the bank maybe
traffic was unusually light maybe he
took a shortcut but there's got to be
some explanation and that explanation
must be consistent with what we already
know to be true
okay so what's the point of this
exercise
it's to show how evidence works and how
conclusions work in the real world when
we get into the jfk assassination
conspiracy theorists will often trumpet
one specific claim or assertion that
they insist is the absolute death knell
for the conclusion that oswald acted
alone
but their reliance on that single claim
or assertion tends to ignore
the rest of the overwhelming totality of
the evidence
or worse pretends like the existence of
that claim or assertion can change the
conclusion that we would otherwise draw
from that evidence let me give you
another example hypothetical one
the oft repeated claim that oswald could
not have recycled the rifle and made
those three shots in 5.6 seconds as
we'll see that claim is factually false
a gunman could easily have done this
with the rifle that oswald was using but
let's just assume just for the sake of
argument that it's remotely possible but
unlikely that it stretches to the very
edge of what is physically possible with
oswald's manliker carcano rifle so does
it matter that it's unlikely no it's
like the claim in the bank robbery
analogy that it seems unlikely that jake
could have gotten as far as he did
before the police caught up with him
that claim does not cut in favor of
jake's innocence though because the rest
of the evidence is so conclusive he did
rob the bank so therefore he must have
driven that distance in 30 minutes
however unlikely that it was
so can a claim about how long it takes
to recycle the rifle change the
ballistics evidence or the eyewitness
that saw oswald do it or the hand prints
on the rifle and the boxes in the sixth
floor depository the sniper's nest can
it change oswald's history his attempt
to kill general walker his conclusively
proven murder of dallas police officer
j.d tippett after the assassination once
you conclude that something happened a
certain way and we are justified in
concluding that that's important we have
to be justified in reaching a conclusion
the facts or assertions that seem
unlikely or inconsistent must be
explainable by some means that line up
with what we've already concluded this
is how the real world works so just keep
this in mind
a shorter way to put this and i know i
need to move on but a shorter way to put
this is if the vast totality of the
evidence indicates x
but some outlier fact or claim seems to
point in the direction of y
don't be so hasty to jettison x and
seize upon y as the basis of a new
conclusion
that is not how logical reasoning works
but that is what often conspiracy
theorists do in the jfk case
okay now finally let's get into the
evidence
the piece of purported evidence of a
conspiracy in the jfk assassination that
has convinced apparently more people
than any other single claim
is the movement or alleged movement of
president kennedy's head just after he
received the fatal shot which is a
horrifying image that is caught on the
supruder film
the claim is that the president's head
snaps backwards in reaction to the
bullet impact which many people say must
be inconsistent
with a shot coming from kennedy's rear
where oswald is known to have been
therefore the story goes this alone is
supposedly proof that the fatal shot
came from the front not the rear the
motion of kennedy's head is itself
repeated as a mantra in the climactic
courtroom scene from oliver stone's 1991
film jfk and it's the title of this
chapter back and to the left back and to
the left
the supruder film is of course the
famous eight millimeter home movie
filmed on a silent camera by dallas
clothing company owner abraham supruder
who was standing here on what's called
the pergola an architectural feature in
dealey plaza
the frames of the film which capture the
moment of the assassination are numbered
starting one
from the first frame of the film that
depicts the motorcade in dealey plaza i
am not going to show you the supruder
film in this video for two reasons first
i'm not sure of the copyright status of
it and i might get a copyright strike
second it is horribly graphic and
triggering after all it captures a human
death on film
and this video would be demonetized
instantly if i showed it
but you can find it here on youtube if
you want to and you can still find you
can find still images of the frames all
over the internet
the moment of the head wound occurs at
frame 313
okay so there are two reasons why the
supposed head snap does not indicate
that president kennedy was hit by a shot
from the front
the first is that what you think you see
in the film what the conspiracy
theorists want you to think that you see
is kennedy's head moving backwards
directly in response to the shot but
that's not what's on the film in fact
the president's head moves forward and
down first in frames 312 and 314 and
only then
does it start moving backwards
because i can't show you the actual
horrible images i've drawn these
hopefully inoffensive stick figures to
demonstrate but they are traced directly
from the frames of the subrouter film if
you want to check my work and see the
actual frames they are reproduced in
bouiose's book in the photo section
between pages 434 and 435.
see here is frame 312 which is where the
bullet strikes and here is 313. this is
super gross
but a junk from kennedy's head is
clearly moving upwards and forwards
only at frame 314 does the infamous head
snap motion start now i'm not distorting
anything go and check the frames of the
zebruda film for yourself
so it is not back to the left but rather
forward and down and then back
the second reason why it doesn't mean
that kennedy was hit by a shot from the
front is that the movement of a person's
head when it is struck by a bullet is
significantly affected by neuromuscular
reaction not the force of the bullet
itself now the house select committee on
assassination spent a considerable
amount of time on this issue
although admittedly not as much as it
should have and it concluded that this
was the cause of the movements of the
president's head when oswald's bullets
struck him so how can a bunch of total
amateurs which is what conspiracy
theorists are
say what a human body must ordinarily do
in response to a catastrophic headshot
i mean unless you've been in combat for
an extensive period of time probably not
that many of us have seen all that many
people shot with high powered rifles so
what frame of reference do we have to
know
how kennedy should or should not have
reacted in this situation
so there you have it first it is not
back and to the left the zubruder film
proves it was forward and down and then
back and second even if that was not the
case we can still explain the image on
the subreddit film entirely consistent
with and entirely supportive of oswald
firing from the book depository behind
the motorcade so if you combine this
evidence that a shot from the front was
probably impossible anyway that's the
myth of the grassy null which i cover in
chapter 10
and it's clear that back and to the left
is not evidence of a second gunman and
certainly not evidence of oswald's
innocence
[Music]
there were three shots fired in dealey
plaza on november 22 1963 three
exactly three not two not four not six
which is the ludicrous claim in oliver
stone's jfk movie three shots one two
three here's how we know first of all
the witnesses who were there that day
many of them told us that there were
three shots
according to the house select committee
on assassinations
132 out of 171 witnesses or 77 percent
reported hearing three shots
even conspiracy author josiah thompson
whose overall conclusions i obviously
don't agreed with studied this issue and
came up with similar numbers 79
out of 190 witnesses reporting three
shots second we know that lee harvey
oswald fired three shots we know that
because of the three empty cartridges
found on the sixth floor at the sniper's
nest which were determined through
ballistics to have been fired from his
manliker carcano rifle and we know those
three cartridges corresponded to the
bullets that wounded president kennedy
and texas governor john connolly
third although the bullets recovered
aren't absolutely conclusive that
exactly three shots were fired
the fragments that were recovered are
consistent with three shots but not more
than that
one nearly whole bullet was found on
governor connolly stretcher at parkland
hospital i'm going gonna be talking
about that bullet specifically in
chapter eight and five bullet fragments
were found in the limousine in which he
was riding with jfk
the mass of all those fragments
recovered was less than the mass of two
whole bullets if there were more than
three shots where did the rest of them
go nobody argues that there were two
shots but conspiracy theorists like to
argue that there were at least four
because they claim erroneously that it's
impossible that one bullet which was the
second one fired by the way could have
wounded both kennely kennedy and
connolly but if kennedy's neck wound
which was made by shot number two and
the wounds to kennedy's back and wrist
which were also made by shot number two
were in fact made by separate shots
where did that additional bullet go it
had to have impacted somewhere in the
limousine right but no such additional
bullet was found
only one from the stretcher and the
fragments which were probably from shot
number three in the mock trial of lee
harvey oswald in london in 1986
prosecutor vincent bulliosi grilled
conspiracy believer dr cyril wecht on
this point where if there was a fourth
shot did it end up he didn't have an
answer
the overwhelming weight of the evidence
i ear witness testimony physical
evidence and logical inferences drawn
from them indicates that there were
three shots fired no more no less
[Music]
more numbers games conspiracy theorists
play a lot of games regarding the amount
of time it would have or could have
taken oswald to fire three shots from
the schoolbook depository
the murder weapon was a bolt action
rifle from the world war ii era and the
way that it works is basically you fire
and then you have to pull back a bolt to
cue up your next shot the fbi which
extensively tested the rifle found that
the minimum amount of time to recycle
between shots was 2.3 seconds 2.3
seconds times 3 is 6.9 seconds however
that does not mean that that would have
taken uh that it would have taken oswald
all of 6.9 seconds to fire three shots
assuming that he had his first one
queued up he would only have had to pull
the bolt twice which means that the
shooting could have been over in as
little as 4.6 seconds
okay so you see how this works he's got
the first rifle cue his first shot
queued up shot number one blam 2.3
seconds to operate the bolt kachink shot
number two blam two point three seconds
to operate the bolt caching shot number
three blam
total four point six seconds elapsed
this is what could have happened in
reality it was a bit slower than that
the sopruder film indicates that the
amount of time elapsed between shot
number two which hit kennedy's back and
neck and went on to wound president or
governor connolly and shot number three
which struck the president in the head
that interval was somewhere between 4.8
seconds and 5.6 seconds
the reason for the range the reason why
we don't know exactly is because the
supruder film is silent we can only
judge that kennedy has been hit from his
reaction and it's not an exact science
as to determining where the reaction
starts
anyway this is how the the phrase 5.6
seconds gets into assassination lore
conspiracy theorists claim erroneously
that the subruder film establishes that
it would have taken oswald 5.6 seconds
to fire all three shots
that's not true at all it could have
taken a considerably shorter time than
that
and conspiracy theorists also claim
erroneously that the rifle could not
have been recycled within that time
frame
now this is this is funny this uh 5.6
seconds claim appears in oliver stone's
1991 film jfk
and in an absolutely epic moment of
self-owning immediately after a
character makes that claim kevin costner
goes on to demonstrate on screen that
you can fire and recycle the manlooker
carcano rifle three times in 5.6 seconds
in fact here's the clip with a time code
to prove it
[Music]
so even if the 5.6 second claim was
correct it's not but even if it was the
fbi and the u.s army proved that it
could have been done
an army sharpshooter named miller
test-fired the exact same rifle at the
same range that oswald was shooting at
kennedy he tried three times
first attempt he got off three shots in
4.6 seconds second attempt was 5.15
seconds third attempt three shots in
4.45 seconds so you see it can be done
and it is absolutely proven that it can
be done
what actually happened probably was that
oswald fired the first shot which missed
at about frame 155 of the supruder film
in fact witnesses several witnesses
claimed they heard a shot that
corresponds to that time
that means that a total of 8.6 seconds
to fire three shots not 5.6 which i
emphasize still could have been done but
8.6
[Music]
aside from the movement of kennedy's
head in reaction to the shot
the other thing that is apparently
highly responsible for selling people on
the idea of a conspiracy is the notion
of the so-called magic bullet
the assertion that the warren commission
concluded that one bullet caused two
wounds to kennedy's back and neck and
then went on to cause two more wounds to
governor connelly and supposedly to in
order to do this it's impossible because
the bullet has to have done something
that defies physics
absolutely false 100 percent
totally false
actually as many people as believe this
erroneous claim it's pretty easy to
debunk
the usual assertion and the one that
filters down to social media level is
that the bullet oswald's second shot had
to have done an s turn in midair in
order to travel from the president's
neck which had exited into governor
connolly's back and then into his wrist
and thigh
conspiracy theorists get there by lying
about how kennedy and connolly were
seated in the limousine in reference to
one another
this lie got started from one single
incorrect sketch called the grodin
sketch which was drawn in 1969
by conspiracy theorist r b cutler the
grodin sketch i'm going to use that term
to refer to all subsequent drawings
based on it like this one but this
sketch shows connolly seated directly in
front of kennedy meaning that the path
of the bullet hitting one and then the
other would indeed have to be s-shaped
but the problem was that there were not
oriented that way connolly was sitting
on a jump seat sticking out of the side
of the limo interior he was not directly
in front of kennedy he was seated ahead
of him and more to the left than kennedy
was
here is a photo of them sitting in the
limousine you can see it's pretty damn
obvious
[Music]
[Applause]
furthermore you can see the orientation
of the limbo seats with your own eyes if
you know where to look
jfk's limo which was used that day is
currently in the henry ford museum in
detroit michigan i went there in 2003
and i saw it myself here's a picture
that i took of it i can tell you that
from my own personal observation which
you can replicate yourself if you go
there in real life connolly's seat is to
the left and the grodin sketch is wrong
so if you show them how they were
actually sitting and you note the
location of the wounds connolly's neck
i'm sorry kennedy's neck connolly's
torso then wrist and thigh in fact they
line up perfectly
so the second shot passes through
kennedy's neck and then hits connolly in
the back there is physical evidence that
this had to be the same bullet that had
passed through kennedy's body
and the evidence is that the entrance
wound on ken on connolly's back was oval
shaped
now let me quote the house select
committee on assassinations on this
point
quote a factor that influenced the panel
significantly was the ovoid shape of the
wound in the governor's back
indicating that the bullet had begun to
tumble or yaw before entering
an ovoid wound is characteristic of one
caused by a bullet that is passed
through or glanced off an intervening
object end quote
so two things about that first it's
physical proof that the bullet had to
have gone some gone through something
before he went on to hit connolly what
else could it have gone through
except kennedy's body
second look again at how they were
sitting connolly was hit in the back
given where they were in relation to the
school book depository how could he have
been hit by a shot that didn't go
through president kennedy first
another misleading reason why conspiracy
theorists refer to this as the so-called
magic bullet is that they say the bullet
was somehow pristine
it was found on governor colin
connolly's stretcher at parkland
hospital it was not at all pristine but
to a certain extent the warren
commission itself promoted this
misconception because the photo that
they happened to choose to publish in
the report makes it look that way and
here is that photo
it does look pretty intact doesn't it
the commission made a mistake by showing
only this photo of the bullet if they
had shown photos of the other side of
the bullet as the house select committee
on assassinations later did it would
have been clear that it wasn't pristine
at all but rather quite squashed as you
see here
an expert who testified for the hsca dr
michael baden said quote this is a very
damaged bullet not a pristine bullet
this is a bullet that is deformed it
would be very hard to take a hammer and
flatten it to the degree to which this
is flattened end quote
so you see the bullet wasn't magic at
all it didn't do anything that violated
the laws of physics and it wasn't
pristine the evidence clearly supports
the conclusion that one bullet caused
the wounds to kennedy's neck and all the
wounds to governor conley this was the
second shot that oswald fired
[Music]
the weapon that oswald used to murder
president kennedy was a manlikar carcano
6.5 caliber bolt action rifle
manufactured in italy in 1940 during
world war ii its serial number was c2766
the rifle which was found on the sixth
floor of the school book depository in
the sniper's nest was modified with a
four power telescopic sight and a
homemade sling made of two leather
straps
what you're looking at incidentally is a
photo that i took of the rifle at the
sixth floor museum in dallas in november
2019.
oswald bought the rifle by mail order
from klein sporting goods in dallas with
a money order for 21.45
dated march 12 1963
this was during the time that oswald was
plotting to kill general edwin walker
which i'll talk about in due course
the rifle was sent to a post office box
assigned to a hidel that was a fake name
that was an alias used by oswald the
money order and the papers for taking
out the post office box were in the
handwriting that was verified by experts
to be lee harvey oswald's
on the night of november 22nd just
before it turned over the rifle to the
fbi the dallas police department got a
palm print from the underside of the
rifle barrel that palm print was
analyzed and found to match the
handprint of lee harvey oswald in
addition to that palm print several
fingerprint traces were discovered on
the trigger now these were not
identifiable at the time of the
assassination nor at the time of the
house select committee 14 years later
but photos of these fingerprint traces
were analyzed in 1993
for a frontline special on the
assassination
the house select committee's fingerprint
expert who was still around looked at
the photos and found 18 points of
identification between them and oswald's
known fingerprints
this guy vincent scalise said on air
quote these are definitely the
fingerprints of lee harvey oswald and
they are on the rifle there is no doubt
about it end quote so did you hear that
no doubt about it in addition several
cotton fibers were found wedged between
the butt of the rifle and the stock they
were blue gray and orange those fibers
matched exactly the shirt that oswald
was wearing when he was arrested on the
afternoon of november 22nd
there is also of course a famous photo
of oswald holding that rifle which was
taken by his wife marina in the spring
of 1963.
conspiracy theorists like to claim that
this photo is faked which oswald also
did when he was being interrogated by
the police but that's nonsense
photographic experts both in 1964 at the
time of the original warren commission
investigation and in the 70s the house
select committee they examined the
pictures and there were actually three
of them and photographic experts proved
that they were genuine to make it even
more certain that the photos weren't
faked one of the prints as i said there
were three of them one of them was even
signed by lee harvey oswald
he gave it to george de moranshilt
pretty much his only friend in april
1963. once again a handwriting was a
match to that known to be of lee harvey
oswald and was proven as such by the
house select committee on assassinations
this evidence is uncontroverted it is
absolutely 100 conclusive lee harvey
oswald bought and owned the rifle his
palm print and his fingerprints were
found on it without any doubt that they
were his it was shipped to his p.o box
there's a photo of him holding it a
photo signed by him in his handwriting
and there are also fibers from his
clothes found snagged on the rifle
and remember the bullets that killed
president kennedy and wounded john
connolly were proven by ballistics to
have been fired from this exact weapon
to the exclusion of all other weapons in
the world bam slam dunk absolutely
conclusive you've got the murder weapon
you've got the murderers fingerprints on
it this evidence alone could have sent
oswald to the electric chair if ruby
hadn't shot him
[Music]
this is the infamous grassy knoll a spot
in dealey plaza where many conspiracy
theorists believe shots were fired at
president kennedy from
this little bit of real estate is to
conspiracy theorists what mecca is to
muslims holy ground
in more recent years this place has
become a pilgrimage site for the deeply
delusional right-wingers who believe in
the qinon conspiracy cult
it's actually bizarre that the grassy
knoll has attracted such attention from
the conspiracy crowd because it's
extremely unlikely that an assassin
could have fired from there
given a choice between the grassy null
and the book depository the grassy null
is a much harder shot
from oswald's point of view in the book
depository the limousine and the
president would be moving a whole lot
less in his field of vision than they
would be from the viewpoint of an
assassin on the grassy null
so the shot from oswald's view in the
depository window at least once the
limousine came out from behind the tree
foliage was a much easier shot
furthermore you're asking us to believe
that the conspirators put a gunman on
ground level surrounded by literally
hundreds of people right out there in
the open where anybody could have seen
what he was doing
as you recall someone down on the ground
level actually saw oswald shooting from
the sixth floor but no one saw a gunman
if he was down there on the ground level
and where would this gunman supposedly
have escaped to after firing from this
position
so this is the key thing if an assassin
was on the grassy knull the only place
he could have run after firing the shots
was through this area known as the
picket fence area
now witness happened to be watching that
exact area at the moment of the
assassination
his name was lee bowers and he was up in
a tower at the railroad yard behind
dealey plaza he didn't see anyone
running away with a gun or anyone
running away period
no one in fact saw anything like that
now i am aware of two fake witnesses
virgil hoffman and jean hill who claimed
that they saw something like that i'm
going to deal with them in chapter 28.
short version they made up their stories
years after the assassination
i'm also aware of the ludicrous british
tv quote unquote documentary series the
men who killed kennedy from 1988 which
has a lot of hijinks involving the
grassy null the silly badge man thing
and i'm going to deal with that in
chapter 30. short version it's nonsense
there are two pieces of physical
evidence absolutely irrefutable that
show that no shots were fired at
president kennedy from the front meaning
the grassy null
the first is the president's autopsy i'm
going to discuss that in chapter 22 but
the short version is that kennedy had
two gunshot wounds one to the neck and
back and one catastrophic wound to the
back and top of his skull
both came from the rear
one of the autopsy surgeons said quote i
did not see any evidence on the dead
body of president kennedy of wounds of
entry on the front portions of the
cadaver end quote
conclusive no shot from the grassy knoll
or anywhere else in the front of the
motorcade
now the second piece of physical
evidence is where the bullet fragments
were found in the president's limousine
personally i found this evidence
extraordinarily persuasive
the large frat bullet fragments were
found in or near the front seat of the
limo the front seat some smaller
fragments were found on the rug under
the left jump seat in front of where
kennedy was sitting if he had been hit
from the front from the grassy knull
why would bullet fragments have been
found forward of him bullets don't
bounce around like rubber balls if
bullet fragments were found in the rear
seat or behind the limo that would be
one thing but they were all found
forward of where kennedy was sitting
this is powerful evidence that shots
came from behind not the front so the
grassy doll is a red herring it just is
no shots came from there no shots could
have come from there
[Music]
now we get to what for me is one of the
most persuasive pieces of evidence of
oswald's guilt
his attempt to kill general edwin walker
on april 10 1963
using the self-same rifle that he would
later use to kill president kennedy in
november of that year so he had done
this kind of thing before
edwin walker was a former u.s army
general and a korean war hero he was a
member of an extreme ultra right-wing
conspiracy cult called the john birch
society the forerunner of today's q anon
which believed that there was a gigantic
communist conspiracy
and all u.s presidents were in on it
walker resigned from the army because of
his belief in this non-existent
conspiracy but he gave a lot of speeches
and continued his political activities
on behalf of the cult
lee harvey oswald was an old an equally
extreme ultra left-wing communist
basically he saw walker as his arch
enemy
so oswald a narcissist also believed
that he had a privileged place in
history and would go down as a hero in
the communist world if he committed a
high-profile political act that was his
motivation
so oswald planned the assassination of
walker very carefully he bought the gun
specifically to do it
he then cased walker's house in dallas
studied bus schedules some assassin he
had to take a bus from his to and from
his big history changing hit
and most tellingly he even wrote a
letter that he left behind for his wife
marina with instructions on who to tell
about his brave and daring act in case
he was captured which he apparently
expected to be
now we know all of this because oswald
himself wrote all this down in a journal
that he kept those famous photos of him
with the rifle the ones the conspiracy
theorists think are fake he had those
pictures taken by his wife because he
thought he would go down in history as
the guy who snuffed the evil general
edwin walker
as i described in chapter 9 we know that
those pictures are not fake they're
genuine and in fact oswald's signature
appears on the back of one of them so
oswald botched the assassination of
walker but not because he was a lousy
shot
at nine o'clock at night on april 10
1963 which is an unusually hot day in
dallas
he took aim at walker who was sitting in
a room working at a desk
visible from oswald's vantage point
through a window
so he fired once and missed and the
bullet instead went into the window
frame
the reason for this is probably because
the glare of the light from the room
made a part of the window frame very
hard to see from oswald's vantage point
he was just unlucky
so we know for a fact that oswald did
this because he confessed to his wife
marina that he had done it
luckily lucky for him she did not tell
the authorities
the bullet that oswald fired at walker
was later examined by the warren
commission it was too damaged to make an
absolute identification but the firearms
expert who looked at it said that it was
entirely consistent with the ammunition
that oswald later used to kill president
kennedy and there was a fair probability
that these bullets were fired from the
same gun
this certainly helps but we don't even
need that evidence to conclude that
oswald did it he confessed
and he took a picture of himself had a
picture of himself taken
using the gun that he did it with so he
was proud of this
i think this is very conclusive oswald
wanted to go down in history as a
political assassin he blew his chance to
do so when he missed walker
unfortunately for the rest of us he got
another chance when kennedy came to town
in november
but note here that oswald did not
collaborate with anyone to try to kill
general walker we know all about this
attempt and it's very clear that there
was no conspiracy to try to kill walker
oswald acted alone in trying to
assassinate edwin walker similarly he
also acted alone in successfully
assassinating president john f kennedy
sadly president john f kennedy was not
the only murderer that lee harvey oswald
committed on that day november 22nd
1963.
he also killed a dallas police officer
j.d tippett at about 1 12 p.m that day
during the time that police were looking
for him after he fled the school book
depository
so i'm not going to spend that much time
on this because it is an absolute slam
dunk there is just no doubt about it
whatsoever
dallas police were fanning out after the
assassination looking for the man who
had been seen at the window of the
school book depository firing at
president kennedy
oswald went home to his rooming house he
changed his clothes and he grabbed a gun
in addition to the rifle that he'd use
he also owned a 38 revolver
at 10th and patton street in dallas a
squad car given driven by officer
tippett encountered oswald and called
him over because he looked like the guy
they were looking for oswald went up to
the car said something to tip it then
pulled out the gun and blew him away
with four shots and tippett died
instantly this murder which occurred
right out in the open in broad daylight
was witnessed by 12 people who either
saw oswald shooting tippit directly or
observed him running away from the scene
this was a murder with 12 a dozen
eyewitnesses furthermore the 38 was
found in oswald's pocket when he was
arrested at the texas theater not long
after
and the bullets that hit officer tippett
proven with ballistics to have been
fired from that exact gun to the
exclusion of all other weapons in the
world
so logically why would oswald have
killed tippett if he wasn't running away
from the assassination of the president
if he was a patsy as he claimed at his
interrogation then why should a police
officer in broad daylight in front of a
dozen witnesses with their own gun
that's just idiotic there is no possible
reason why he would have done this that
doesn't implicate him in the
assassination of kennedy he knew they
were looking for the guy who shot the
president he knew he was the guy who
shot the president
when tippett spotted him and called him
out he knew he'd been cornered killing
the officer was a last-ditch super
desperate attempt at an escape not very
well thought out though
there's just nothing more to say on this
he did it and it's direct evidence of
his guilt in the assassination of
president kennedy
[Music]
if you like what i'm doing here don't
just subscribe although of course it
would be great if you did that but it'd
be really helpful for you to click on
one of my other videos
i have several on various other
historical mysteries or false narratives
of history and i have a lot of videos on
various nautical topics
i'm primarily a historian but i'm also
an author and teacher i teach history
courses online at my website
shawnmonger.com
i've also got several books available on
amazon including a crime thriller it's
called the sun thief that's the sequel
to in deadly mirrors
i also wrote a science fiction book
called the valley of forever
i have a patreon that's patreon.com
sean munger or you can donate to my kofi
the link is in the description to this
video
i'll also put a link to my sub stack
blog sean monger history dot sub stack
dot com where i write about world
problems from a historical standpoint
thanks so much for your support sorry to
interrupt the flow let's get back to the
subject of the kennedy assassination
[Music]
so how did lee harvey oswald come up
with the plan to shoot president kennedy
the evidence shows that he didn't spend
a lot of time planning it it was mostly
a lucky accident
which came about fundamentally as the
result of a total coincidence that the
root of kennedy's motorcade was planned
to pass in front of the building where
oswald happened to work
i think this evidence is really
interesting because it tends to prove
that there was no conspiracy that oswald
was not working with anyone
kennedy's visit was planned by the
secret service beginning on november 4th
1963 only a couple of weeks before the
assassination
the motorcade was ultimately headed to
the dallas trade mart where kennedy
would have made a speech
now this is really interesting the
selection of the trademart as a location
didn't even appear in any dallas papers
until november 15th a week before the
event it was reported in the dallas
times herald on that day
and the motorcade route which was not
even finalized until november 18th was
first published also in the dallas times
herald on november 19th only three days
before the assassination the morning
news also carried a story on it this was
how oswald found out about the motorcade
and realized that it would pass in front
of his building only three days before
the assassination
honestly if this was some deep-seated
plot to kill jfk don't you think that
the conspirators would have spent months
planning this in advance how could it
have been thrown together in just three
days it just doesn't make any sense
furthermore here's another important
fact oswald hadn't even worked at the
texas school book depository for very
long he applied for that job on october
15th
now the depository the the institution
of the school book depository actually
had two buildings one was on dealey
plaza and the other was on houston
street which was very far from the
motorcade route
the manager of this company one roy
truly assigned oswald to work at the
depository on dealey plaza and another
man who applied for a job that same day
to work on houston street he could just
as easily have assigned oswald to
houston street and then he wouldn't have
had the opportunity to assassinate
president kennedy this is powerful
evidence that there was no conspiracy
oswald wasn't working for anyone when he
shot the president if he was how come
the conspirators left it up to a book
company manager to decide
whether their trigger man would be in
place in range of the motorcade and if
you say well roy truly must have been in
on it well how could he have known that
the motorcade was going to pass by that
spot if the decision for that route
wasn't even made until november 18th and
truly assigned oswald to the dealey
plaza location on october 15th
this fact alone without anything else is
proof that to me at least that oswald
was not part of a conspiracy
so here's another really interesting
piece of evidence
at the time of the assassination oswald
was estranged from his wife marina
whom he'd met when he lived in the
soviet union after his defection there
in 1959.
they were separated at the time marina
was living at the house of a friend ruth
payne and hers and oswald's two children
were with her
so oswald rented a tiny room in this
boarding house this is the room that he
returned to after the shooting after
shooting kennedy to pick up his gun just
before he blew away officer tippett
anyway in the days before the
assassination during the time that he
must have been planning it meaning after
november 19th when the motorcade route
was made public and november 22nd
oswald tried to reconcile with his wife
marina he said that he was going to get
an apartment where they could all live
together with the kids and he wanted her
to join him there
oswald did not have a car he usually
asked a friend wesley frazier to drive
him over to ruth payne's house to see
his wife marina
this always happened on weekends and by
special arrangement
wesley frazier full name buell wesley
frazier also worked at the texas school
book depository
a number of the oswald's possessions
including the rifle that he had used to
shoot edwin walker were stored in ruth
payne's garage
on thursday november 21st the day before
the assassination oswald asked if he
could ride with frazier to the payne
house
he said he wanted to pick up some
curtain rods to put in the apartment
that he was renting
this was the first time that oswald had
gone to the paint's house on a night
other than a weekend and the first time
he ever came unannounced
[Music]
so frazier drove him over there oswald
got the quote-unquote curtain rods from
the garage obviously the rifle hidden in
brown paper and strapping tape and that
wrapping was later found in the sniper's
nest oswald also talked to marina and
asked her one more time if she'd come
back to him so that they could live
together
she said later that she really thought
about it but she wanted to hold out a
little longer
in retrospect it seems like this this
conversation with marina was his
go-no-go decision
if she had decided to go back to him if
she said yes that night he probably
would not have done it but if she didn't
go for it which he must have known was
likely he was going to kill the
president the next day and he had the
rifle ready to go in fact marina herself
thought this is what happened she told
the warren commission that if she knew
her husband was planning to whack the
president if she didn't go back to him
that night she definitely would have
so oswald spent that night with marina
at the payne house when he got up to go
to work the next morning this is friday
november 22nd he left money for her on
the bureau 170 dollars in cash
and he left something else his wedding
ring which had been manufactured in the
soviet union it was very distinctive in
fact here is a photo that i took of the
ring in 2019 it's in the sixth floor
museum in dallas the 170 dollars that he
left her was almost all the money that
oswald had in the world that both
oswald's had in the world
now there are many pieces of evidence in
this case that even standing alone
without anything else strongly indicate
oswald's guilt and the fact that there
was no conspiracy and this is one of
them why on earth would he have done
this if he wasn't planning to shoot the
president
it indicates that he decided to do it
and also that he thought it was pretty
likely that he wasn't going to get away
with it the chances were good that he'd
either be killed or arrested this was
his final goodbye to his wife for all
intents and purposes
now we know that oswald wanted to get
away with it if that was at all possible
we know that because he ran away from
the book depository and he also shot
officer tippett but leaving the money in
the wedding ring clearly shows his frame
of mind he didn't think he was going to
be successful
interestingly he also did something
similar before the walker attempt
leaving marina a message
telling her who to tell about his
attempt and how to publicize it so that
he would go down in history books as the
great communist hero that he wanted to
be
so we're totally seeing into oswald's
mind here his wife rejected him he
figured it was over he would never have
another chance to make history and go
down as a big communist hero he expected
more or less to give his life in the
process
folks this is how it happened it could
not be clearer if you think about it if
you really think about the logic of it
this chapter alone proves that oswald
acted by himself
[Music]
the most famous declaration that oswald
made while he was in custody was in the
presence of tv news reporters in the
dallas jail about 7 55 pm on the evening
of the assassination
a reporter asked him did you shoot the
president and oswald responded quote no
they've taken me in because of the fact
that i have lived in the soviet union
i'm just a patsy end quote
people who believe there was a
conspiracy in the jfk assassination and
that oswald was innocent have seized on
these words as literal truth i'm just a
patsy
which they take to mean that oswald was
framed by the true conspirators to
deflect blame away from them
but if you think about this claim
logically and especially when you
consider it in conjunction with the
actual evidence of oswald's guilt it
turns out that that view doesn't make a
whole lot of sense
so first point that proves that he was
not a patsy
assume just for the sake of this example
that there was a conspiracy to kill
kennedy and that oswald was somehow part
of it
he clearly did not volunteer to take the
fall he ran away from the school book
depository and he even killed police
officer j.d tippett in a pretty futile
attempt to escape once cornered at the
texas theater oswald tried to fight off
the police officers who were closing in
on him this is all unquestionable
evidence that he wanted to try to get
away if he could
so if he was part of a conspiracy to
kill kennedy and if he did not volunteer
to take the fall it can only be that the
other conspirators told him that he
could get away
and they and that they obviously reneged
on whatever arrangements they may have
told him that they'd make to that effect
so once he was in custody it would have
been obvious to oswald that his
co-conspirators had abandoned and
sacrificed him thrown him to the wolves
so to speak
so in that situation why didn't oswald
implicate his co-conspirators
if he was just the trigger man and the
patsy to boot the authorities would be
very interested in going higher up the
chain to find the big fish who was
really responsible for the whole thing
right i mean that only makes sense
if oswald cooperated with them he might
have been able to cut some kind of deal
with the authorities in exchange for his
testimony against his superiors
so why didn't he implicate anyone else
oswald was in custody for two days from
the afternoon of friday november 22nd to
the late morning of sunday november 24th
when he was himself assassinated by jack
ruby in all of the statements that he
made to police many of which were
patently false and made no sense he
never implicated anyone else
but as you see here not only did oswald
have every reason in the world to point
the finger at someone else
in fact after he was captured it was the
only possible way that he might have
been able to escape or reduce the
punishment that he would face
which we know for a fact that he very
much wanted to do because he went so far
as to gun down a police officer in cold
blood in an unsuccessful attempt to get
away
this whole scenario gets even more
far-fetched if you consider what most
jfk conspiracy theorists think about
jack ruby which is that he killed oswald
on november 24th to silence him and
prevent him from doing the exact thing
that i just said was his only possible
way out if he was involved in a plot but
oswald had not yet done that at the time
ruby killed him after he'd been already
been in custody for two days
if oswald could have implicated anyone
else which is what conspiracy theorists
think then why did he wait two whole
days to do it why not blab the moment
they started questioning him or at least
tell the authorities i can tell you
who's behind the assassination make me a
deal but oswald never said that nothing
of the kind
the reason why oswald didn't implicate
anyone else is very simple because there
was no one else to implicate he did it
alone
no co-conspirators once more this alone
virtually proves that there was no
conspiracy
second point that proves that he wasn't
a patsy the scenario that i just talked
about and debunked is that oswald was
knowingly part of a conspiracy to kill
the president that he was up there in
the book depository doing the shooting
but that he was doing it on behalf of
someone else however many jfk conspiracy
theorists maintained that he was
completely innocent that someone else
was doing the shooting from up there and
oswald was just the poor sap that they
pinned it on in other words that he was
unknowingly part of the conspiracy by
way of being set up to be the fall guy
but this makes no sense either
framing an innocent oswald as the patsy
could only work if the conspirators
could be confident that he would not be
able to prove his innocence if he wasn't
up there in the sniper's nest on the
sixth floor wouldn't it have been easy
for oswald to prove that he was
somewhere else at the time the shots
were fired
take this interesting fact
most of the other employees of the texas
school book depository were outside the
building on the street watching the
motorcade at the time of the
assassination a smaller number of school
book depository employees were watching
from the fifth floor that was one floor
below the sniper's nest
in fact when the shots were fired those
employees who were gathered on the fifth
floor definitely heard the shots the
building shook and little bits of gravel
and dust fell from the ceiling on their
heads
one witness harold norman even heard the
shell casings hit the floor after the
shot
well i was uh looking out the window and
uh
the first shot was fired
well it you know i didn't take much of
it because it kind of you know shook the
building a little bit really it was just
that powerful
then after the second shot was fired
when i saw
the people they were all falling on the
ground and
i told one of the photos i said that
shot came from this building and uh then
by the time i got done the third shot
and one of the guys told him so i
believe you're right and i'd say i know
it did
and then i could you know
also hear the whole empty hose hitting
the cartridges hitting the floor and i
could hear the rejection of the rifle
whatever it was i don't
if oswald was innocent and if he had
either gone outside or up to the fifth
floor to watch the motorcade with the
other employees
which the chances of him doing were very
high because almost all the employees
did that he would have had an unshakable
alibi many of his co-workers who knew
him on site would be able to testify
that he was with them at the moment the
shots were fired all of their stories
would line up and he would escape blame
so how would the conspirators have known
that oswald would be somewhere at the
moment of the assassination where he
wouldn't be surrounded by multiple
witnesses who could prove where he was
if he just happened by chance to be
somewhere with a lot of people who could
identify him the whole assassination
plot falls apart because oswald wouldn't
have been available to be the fall guy
this could not work at all unless oswald
was working for somebody and they told
him to be on the sixth floor at a
certain time and the shots came from
somewhere else in which case we're back
to the first scenario i described where
oswald would knowingly have done
something for somebody whom he could
implicate as soon as he realized he was
being set up for a presidential
assassination so oswald was not a patsy
there's not any kind of scenario that
makes any sense and is supported by the
slightest shred of evidence where
oswald's words i'm just a patsy could be
literal truth
lee harvey oswald did it and he did it
alone there's tons of other evidence to
point to exactly this same conclusion
but i think that the logical reasoning
i've gone through in this chapter is
sufficient all by itself to enable us to
come to this conclusion independently
[Music]
so now we get into the subject of
oswald's assassin jack ruby now i'm not
going to talk a whole lot about him
the conventional wisdom such as it is
among conspiracy theorists is that
ruby was a mafia hitman who supposedly
silenced oswald to prevent him from
implicating the real conspirators
in the last chapter i explained why that
belief is wrong and extremely
far-fetched but here we'll get into how
we know that ruby was not a hitman and
why he did what he did
jack ruby dallas nightclub owner was a
highly emotional man with a quick temper
and a propensity for violence
the fbi interviewed nearly a hundred
people who knew him very well and almost
every single one of them commented on
his emotional nature and his hot temper
such as for a representative example one
billy joe willis who was a drummer at
ruby's carousel club and who knew ruby
very well he testified that he was quote
a highly emotional person who had no
control over his emotions so that's just
one example there are many many more
ruby was incredibly distraught at the
news of president kennedy's
assassination
not only did he close his own carousel
club out of respect for the president
but he called up other business owners
in dallas and urged them to close their
establishments too
he went to synagogue to pray for kennedy
and years later his sister eva told
historian vincent bulliosi that jack
quote cried harder when president
kennedy was killed than when ma and pa
died end quote not only was ruby
distraught at the assassination but he
wanted to and actively tried to
participate in events surrounding it
for example he went to parkland hospital
where kennedy died and then after oswald
was arrested he started hanging around
the dallas city hall where the jail was
where oswald was being held
a witness claimed quote if there was one
ruby trait that stands out it's that he
had to be where the action was
that's why the president's assassination
and all the follow-up activity at the
jail with oswalt and the press attracted
jack like a magnet it was a natural for
him end quote
ruby in fact went to police headquarters
on friday evening and he was present in
the hallway outside the door where
oswald was being interrogated ruby was
very friendly with the dallas police of
course we know he was back at the
station on sunday morning november 24th
coincidentally at the exact time that
oswald was about to be moved from dallas
police hq to the county jail
ruby had been hanging around in that
part of town and in fact he was at the
western union telegraph office near
police headquarters until just a few
minutes before the oswald shooting he
was carrying a gun that was usual for
him
and ruby slipped into police
headquarters basement where security was
lacked and seized his opportunity to run
right up and shoot oswald point blank
most of you have probably seen the photo
of this event i'm not going to show it
because i think it's a little too
graphic for what i want this video to be
the circumstances of ruby's shooting of
oswald prove and i deliberately use that
word prove that the killing was
completely opportunistic
now this is what author norman mailer
had to say about this issue in a 1995
article
quote why was ruby standing online in
western union waiting to waiting his
turn to send 25 to a stripper while time
kept floating away and oswald might be
moved at any moment the question cannot
be answered how many confederates and
most of them had to be police would be
necessary to coordinate such a move
no one who is the key figure in a
careful schedule that will reach its
climax as the target is being
transferred is going to be found
dawdling across the street at a western
union office with only a few minutes to
go it would take hours for a stage
director to begin to choreograph such a
scene for an opera end quote
furthermore ruby himself told us how
this all came about
on july 18 1964 ruby was given a
polygraph test observed by the fbi in
the warren commission so here are some
excerpts from that interview these are
direct quotes question did you decide to
shoot oswald on saturday night no
did you first decide to shoot oswald on
sunday morning
yes
did you shoot oswald because of any
influence of the underworld no
did you shoot oswald in order to save
mrs kennedy the ordeal of a trial
yes end quote
now it is true that polygraph or lie
detector tests are not conclusive and
there was serious question as to ruby's
mental state which was always a little
shaky
but the test showed no obvious
indication of deception ruby volunteered
very heavily to take it
in the total absence of any evidence
or facts to the contrary i think we can
conclude that it's more likely than not
that ruby was telling the truth in this
interview that he did not work for the
mafia and that his decision to blow
oswald away was basically a spur of the
moment opportunistic one
furthermore the ruby worked for the
mafia gag makes no sense if there is no
other evidence that the mafia was in any
way connected to the assassination and
there isn't see chapter 23 for a greater
exploration of that issue
look it's very clear ruby did not work
for the mafia and he did not shoot
oswald to silence him he was an unstable
emotional and violent man who seized his
once-in-a-lifetime opportunity to kill
the assassin of president kennedy no
evidence to support any other narrative
has ever been revealed
[Music]
a gigantic and unsolvable problem with
the idea that oswald was part of a
conspiracy to kill president kennedy is
that as a practical matter there's
absolutely no way that a group of
high-level political conspirators could
have relied on oswald to do anything the
man was so completely incompetent at
almost everything and he was incapable
completely incapable of working with or
taking orders from anyone that the more
you know about him the more laughable
the idea becomes that he could have been
part of some big plot
in my opinion the most illuminating part
of vincent bouliose's mammoth book on
the assassination this gigantic thing
is the section that is the exhaustive
biography of lee harvey oswald now this
section is 275 pages long and has over
1600 source notes everything that you
could ever want to know about this man
is here and it's exhaustively detailed
now the warren report also has a much
more condensed biography of oswald but
it's not nearly as in-depth and doesn't
illuminate the main point that i'm
talking about here nearly as well as
bouliose's independent investigation
oswald who was only 24 at the time he
killed president kennedy was a violent
unpleasant and incompetent loser he
failed at almost everything he attempted
in his life
he couldn't hack it as a u.s marine was
given an undesirable discharge he
defected to the soviet union convinced
that communism was a beacon of light for
the world but he couldn't hack that
either the soviets were about to deport
him but he attempted suicide to try to
manipulate them eventually he soured on
russia and returned to the u.s with his
wife marina whom he had married there he
couldn't hack it as a husband his
marriage was in shambles at the time of
the assassination
he kept drifting around
dallas to new orleans to dallas again he
could hardly hold down a menial minimum
wage job he'd only worked at the book
depository a little more than a month
before the assassination
in the summer of 1963 when conspiracy
theorists would have you believe that
the assassination was being carefully
planned oswald got it in his head that
he would go and try and defect again
this time to cuba
he went to mexico city to try to get
documents to enable him to do that he
failed that and returned home
empty-handed everybody who encountered
oswald knew instantly that he was a
loser when he defected to the soviet
union in 1959 at first the kgb thought
he might be useful but then this
happened a high kgb official said this
quote oswald turned out to be a mediocre
uninteresting man we had high
expectations of him as an informant but
nothing ever came of it we realized
oswald was a useless man end quote ruth
payne a friend of marina oswald remember
she was living at ruth payne's house at
the time of the assassination she knew
lee harvey oswald well
when asked at the 1986 mock trial of
lee harvey oswalt in london when she was
asked this question
do you feel he was the type one would
employ to accomplish a serious mission
ruth payne answered quote no i would not
have employed him for any job i didn't
see him as stable enough end quote
historian patricia mcmillan who wrote a
book about the married life of marina
and lee harvey oswald says this in her
book quote i have often asked marina
whether lee might have been capable of
joining with an accomplice to kill the
president
never she says lee was too secretive
ever to have told anyone his plans nor
could he have acted in concert accepted
orders or obeyed any plan by anyone else
lee acted on impulse and first thought
seriously of killing the president only
a day or two before he did it end quote
that is the opinion of the person who
knew oswald better than anyone else in
the world
now it is true years later in the 80s
marina did change her opinion and became
a conspiracy theorist after constant
exposure to jfk conspiracy material
but it's certainly telling that before
that happened she told the warrant
commission and maintained for years
afterward even to her biographer
patricia mcmillan that her late
husband's personality was completely
unsuited for him to be working with
anyone on something as sensitive as a
political assassination
this is a guy with no track record no
significant significant education
minimal life skills minimal job skills
even his own wife can't stand to be
around him for very long a record a long
record of erratic behavior a political
extremist who didn't even understand the
politics that he thought he was
supporting recall how disillusioned he
became after living in the soviet union
why would high-level political
conspirators trust this guy to shine
their shoes how could they be sure that
he'd follow their orders how could they
be sure that he wouldn't betray them to
save his neck it doesn't make any sense
now i said that oswald was incompetent
and a failure at almost everything he
did in his entire life the one thing
that he did in his life that did succeed
unfortunately was killing the president
of the united states he was a pretty
decent marksman contrary to what
conspiracy theorists will tell you and
fate happened to put him in the right
place at the right time when he read in
the papers that kennedy's motorcade was
going to pass right in front of the
building where he happened to work
it's an absolute shame and a horribly
unlucky accident of history that the one
time in his entire life that this
miserable screw-up does something right
it's to do something like this
but it was not a conspiracy
oswald was completely untrustworthy you
wouldn't hire a guy like this to flip
burgers much less to work as part of a
team to achieve a complicated political
objective
[Music]
an extremely persuasive piece of
evidence that indicates that oswald was
not working for anybody is that he was
virtually broke at the time of the
assassination
now the warrant commission did an
excellent job of tracking oswald's
household finances down to the last
penny
you may remember that on the morning of
the assassination oswald left some money
and his wedding ring for his wife marina
probably because he knew he wouldn't be
coming back
he left her a hundred and seventy
dollars in cash
you know how much money he had on his
person when the police arrested him 13
and 87 cents
so put those together this is all the
money that he had in the entire world
183 dollars and 87 sets
almost all jfk conspiracy theorists
think that lee harvey oswald was some
sort of secret agent who was working for
somebody right-wing elements of the u.s
government or the kgb or the mafia or
somebody but was working for somebody
for years before the assassination that
claim is absolutely ridiculous
if he was what were they paying him he
and marina lived hand to mouth they were
constantly broke
if he was a big cia or kgb agent gearing
up for this big caper and his job at the
book depository or his other previous
menial jobs were just fronts
then where is the evidence that he was
spending more than he made from these
menial jobs
oswald didn't even have a car
he fled the assassination and got away
from dealey plaza on a city bus
these agencies that oswald supposedly
worked for they didn't even get him a
car even an old clunker apparently not
the rifle that oswald used to kill
president kennedy cost
21.45 cents oswald paid for it himself
with a money order that was conclusively
traced
don't you think the conspirators would
have given him a state-of-the-art sniper
rifle probably costing thousands of
dollars for this the most important job
that they would ever pull off and again
oswald had used that exact same 21 gun
to try to kill general walker in april
1963.
so those who insist that oswald was part
of a conspiracy to kill kennedy want us
to believe first that he received
absolutely no monetary compensation for
being part of this plan and second that
he'd worked for some intelligence or
other group absolutely for free for
years prior to the assassination and
third that the conspirators were so
cheap that they forced oswald to buy his
own rifle and bring it from home to
commit the biggest political
assassination of the 20th century this
makes absolutely zero sense the fact
that oswald was broke which we can prove
beyond all doubt is itself evidence that
there was no conspiracy
[Music]
this is the break point between the
first segment of this video and the
second
so please continue on to part two of
oswald act alone the jfk assassination
solved the same number scheme of the
chapters is going to apply there
so that's why we're going to pick up
there with chapter 20. thanks very much
in the meantime please like subscribe
share do all the stuff that you normally
do for a video you like and i'll see you
in the next segment
[Music]
you